[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Why did you
join the Coast Guard?
KORI CIOCA: Well,
I always knew I
was going to join the military
ever since I was a little kid.
And I loved every minute of it.
And it was like nobody was
male, nobody was female.
We were a family.
I'm very small, petite.
But there, I felt like I was
this Great Dane in a Chihuahua
body.
I could do anything as long as
my teammates were next to me.
LAURA LING: So things
seemed like they
were going very well for you.
And you had a great team.
But you also had some very
traumatic situations happen
to you with your supervisor.
What was going on?
KORI CIOCA: Well, he would
follow me around and call me
all sorts of names
that are inappropriate.
And he gave me extra
duty all the time.
But when other people would
try to stick up for me,
it seemed like he would
retaliate against me,
but more if I went for help.
He would drink on
duty, get drunk.
And he'd unlock
my door at night.
And it made me very
scared and frightened.
And I would speak to
my command members.
And they would say,
we're not going
to move you just because you
don't like somebody, Cioca.
So just go back out there.
I couldn't understand why
it was happening to me.
Why wasn't anyone doing
anything to help me?
I didn't have a voice anymore.
Everything just kept escalating.
I mean, he would
spit in my face.
And it was like he
was breaking me down.
He pinned me down.
And anytime I would try
to say something-- help,
or please stop, please,
please-- he would hit me.
But he'd hit me right in
my ear on the left side.
And I shut up.
But this man did say he
was going to kill me.
He did everything he said
he was going to do to me.
Even did something-- he never
said he was going to rape me,
and he did.
And that was the one I
wasn't expecting at all.
That was the moment that
he knocked that Great Dane
right out of me.
LAURA LING: Was it
from that point on that
you left the Coast Guard?
What happened to
you at that point?
KORI CIOCA: I was getting
treatment for my injuries.
And that's when
they gave me orders.
And they discharged me.
And he got 30 days restriction.
He got bumped down in rank.
And that's really
sad that, I mean,
this crime is just happening.
And nobody's blinking
an eye at it.
That's not the Coast
Guard that I joined.
And at that point, I just
didn't want to be here anymore.
I didn't want to be alive.
LAURA LING: What were
some of the things that
have helped you cope?
KORI CIOCA: It actually started
when I was getting treatment.
So in my off time, I would
buy a disposable camera.
And I would go and I would
take pictures of the lake.
I met Rob.
And I would take pictures
of Rob in the Coast Guard,
him doing his job.
I love taking pictures.
It took away from what
was happening in my head.
Now if I'm triggered
by something,
or if I have nightmares all
night, I grab my camera.
And I focus on what's
important through that lens.
So I'm thinking of all these
other things rather than
my trauma and my
trigger at the moment.
It helps my brain switch gears.
I'll go out and I will
just walk somewhere.
Abandoned places are
probably my most favorite.
There's something so
beautiful about it.
It really relates to
someone with PTSD.
And a lot of people will look at
you and say, well, you look OK.
You look put together.
You look well.
And they have no idea, because
PTSD is an invisible disorder.
And if you were to take
a veteran with PTSD
and turn them inside
out, they would
be just like that abandoned
building-- broken windows.
It's just beautiful
about the way
that it's still
standing after it's
been forgotten and destroyed.
LAURA LING: Do you feel like
you finally found your voice
through photography?
KORI CIOCA: I have.
It helps me understand myself.
I can see at that time when
I took that picture, oh, it's
dark.
I must've been
really sad that day.
Or was that a hard day.
And there's one that's
really bright, and happy,
and beautiful.
That was a good day.
When I look through my
lens, I see my kids smiling.
I see them happy.
And it's like, I win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Coming
up next, see how
swimming became the unlikely
ritual of a woman who nearly
lost her ability to walk.
KIMBERLEY CHAMBERS:
My next memory
is waking up post-surgery,
30 minutes from amputation
from the knee down.
I remember the surgeon
telling me, we saved your leg.
But we don't know what, if any,
functionality you'll ever have.
I told myself I was going
to prove them wrong.
[MUSIC PLAYING]